So, the answer is 3. Why is that? Well, here's the code. Let's take it step by
step. First of all, every thread is setting a local variable equal to it's own
thread index. Then in this line, we're declaring a shared variable, which is
going to be shared by all of the threads in the thread block. I just hardcoded
in 128 elements here. And now we're actually going to do something. We're going
to write every thread is going to write into a single element of the array
corresponding to it's thread index. And the thing that it's going to write into
that element of the array happens to be its own thread index, okay? So, this is
going to load up that array with one, two, three, four, and so on. And that's
just to put something in the array that we can play with. This operation is
right. So, we need a barrier after this write completes in order to make sure
that nobody tries to read from the array until after all of the threads have
finished the write operation. So, let's insert a barrier here. And now, all of
the threads that pass this if statement are going to do this shift operation,
right? They're going to set the array at their index to the array at their
index plus one. But if you think about it, this is really a read and a write
operation. Here was our first write operation. That was number 1. And now,
we're doing a read operation. That's number 2. Okay, we're going to read from
the array at index plus 1. And then, finally we're going to write to the array
at index. And that's operation three. And the tricky thing about this is that
all of these reads should complete before we allow any of these writes to
finish. So, really we need to restructure this code. We'll make this read
operation explicit, put in a local temporary variable. We'll call the same
threads. We'll perform the write operation explicitly, and then just to be
absolutely safe before anybody can use these written values. We needed another
synchthreads to ensure that all of these write operations have completed before
anybody attempts to do anything with this array value afterwards.